[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAMIE SIDEY: Today
we're going to talk
about how to save 80% or
more by migrating your data
center into GCP.
My name is Jamie Sidey.
I'm chief of staff
of Optiva, and I've
been here for about two years.
And I've been focused
on the operational side
of private equity
for about five years.
My role is to look at
the cost and expense
side of the businesses
that we get involved in.
Typically, these are financially
distressed, bankrupt,
out of cash.
No other private equity
or venture capital group
wants to touch them.
So we were very excited
when we found Optiva.
It was deeply
financially distressed,
but the core product
was really good,
which made it a great fit
for our type of turnaround.
KEITH MILLAR: And
I'm Keith Millar.
I'm the senior vice president
of Pythian Services Business,
and we were the
services provider
who was chosen to help Optiva
in this migration to GCP.
JAMIE SIDEY: So just
to set the stage--
what is it that Optiva does?
When you place a phone call or
use data on your mobile phone,
there's a split second
where your carrier
has to determine who are you?
Are you prepaid, postpaid?
Are you one of my
subscribers, somebody else's?
How am I going to get paid?
It's not a particularly
sexy piece of software.
But it's super important.
If it goes down, then
either the carrier
has to not let
anything go through.
And then all the subscribers
get super grumpy.
Or the carrier lets
things go through,
but they don't get paid.
So uptime is super important.
In terms of what we're
bringing to the table post
turnaround for innovation,
we're taking this and moving it
to public cloud.
So telco is a very
conservative risk averse space,
and they also have to
provision for peak load.
So not anything particularly
new, but from our perspective,
well, why don't you
move to somewhere
where you can provision for the
load that you actually need?
So instead of provisioning
for Mother's Day, which
happens once a year
and as multiples
of what they need
the rest of the year,
they can scale up
and scale down.
So we have 100 plus
customers all over the world,
billions of transactions
per hour at peak.
Here's some of our customers.
One of the things that's been
interesting for me in getting
involved in this business,
I follow world events a lot
more closely than I used to.
So if there's a coup, or
a civil war, or whatever--
I mean, we have
customers in Afghanistan,
and Yemen, and Venezuela,
all over the place.
And I'm much more aware
of what's happening now
because it impacts our
customers immediately.
KEITH MILLAR: Sure,
I'll just give you
some insight as to Pythian's
sort of the opportunity
we see on Google Cloud Platform.
We're 20 years in business,
400 employees, 350 customers
globally.
But it really kind of wraps up
in the love your data tag line.
So we've always been good at
focusing on where the data is
or where it's going.
And right now, we see a
lot of data going to GCP.
So that's what we're excited
about with the Google
opportunity.
What do we do?
What does Pythian do on GCP?
There's really two
main scenarios.
One is the one we're talking
about today with Optiva,
moving bare metal or VMs
from on-prem into GCP.
And that can be either on to
Google Cloud Compute Engine
or onto Kubernetes.
So that's mostly what we're
going to talk about today.
The other piece is
there's a lot of optimism
in the market around
what the cloud provides
as a next generation
analytics platform.
So leveraging things
like BigQuery on GCP,
linking your legacy data
sources to that data warehouse,
and then using tools
like Look or Tableau
to gain those
insights once you've
got the real time streaming
infrastructure in place.
For all of those scenarios,
there's really some key things
that we talk about all the time.
Security, how do you set
up Google Security Console
from day one and have people
attending to those alerts 24/7?
Same with op vis, Stackdriver,
setting that up on day one,
and then dealing
with those 24/7.
And really, the order of
magnitude change or complexity
that comes with Cloud is
quite apparent to us, so
evolutionary services.
Once you've got a stack
set up in GCP coming in
on a quarterly basis and saying,
OK, here's what's changed.
Here are the new pieces
that are available.
Here's the ones we
suggest you drop,
or here's the new
ones that you adopt.
So that's just
sort of how Pythian
looks at the GCP opportunity.
JAMIE SIDEY: So what was the
mess that we started with?
When we got
involved, the company
spending about 15 million a
year on data center, which
with a base of revenue of about
150 million and the company
wasn't a SaaS company, 15
million a year is a lot.
10 data centers,
tens of thousands
of square foot of space,
millions a year on electricity,
100 engineers just to
supporting the data centers.
This type of location
proliferation
is not actually
unusual when you've
got a company that's formed
by multiple successive
acquisitions.
Each division that comes in
brings with it its own data
centers, its own
team, and each team
feels that they have specific
unique expertise that's
very hard to replace.
Which they do have
specific expertise,
and it is hard to
replace, but if you
don't have the discipline to
consolidate, then over time,
eventually you get to
spending 15 million in a year
and just hemorrhaging money.
So our big idea,
for those of you
who read Built to
Last back in the 90s,
the BHAG, the big,
hairy, audacious goal
was to save 90%, going
from 15 million a year
to 1 and 1/2 million
a year in six months.
We met with the
team that was there
at the time we got
involved and said, OK,
how can we shrink
this 15 million?
And they said, well, if we
do this, we can save 10%.
And then if we do
this, we can get to 20.
And if we get really aggressive,
maybe we can get to 30% or 40%.
And we said mm, and how
long is that going to take?
And they were like,
two, maybe three years,
if we're really disciplined.
We're like, ah,
we're bleeding here.
We can't wait that long.
So instead, what
we said was, let's
move everything possible to GCP.
And then everything
that can't move to GCP,
let's pick one data center,
and centralize there, and then
optimize like crazy after that.
So how do you move 10
data centers into Google?
Well, step zero really is
pick your cloud provider.
And it's worth mentioning
why we picked Google.
Our customers, as I
mentioned, are telcos.
They're very risk averse.
And so they're dealing with
super sensitive personal data--
name, phone number, location.
And so they can't
have data breaches.
So when you walk in,
and you're able to point
to the huge investment that
Google has made in security,
that helps de-escalate
that, especially
if you can walk in with Google
people to talk about that.
So that takes that
off the table.
The next reason we picked
Google was the native products.
So we spent a ton on
Oracle every year,
and we'd prefer to
spend like zero.
So we started
experimenting with Spanner,
and we found that we
got better performance.
The price was better.
And we got better
reliability, which
is a trifecta that you
just don't find very often.
KEITH MILLAR: On that topic,
an interesting part of this
is this Oracle to
Spanner migration.
And one of the things
you hear about Spanner
is because it's the
replication anywhere idea,
you've got GDPR
compliance issue.
How did you deal with
Spanner in that setup?
JAMIE SIDEY: Yeah, so
that comes up with most
of the conversations we have.
And at least initially, we're
keeping people in one region.
So if you want to
be in Europe, then
stay within the European zones.
Originally, we were thinking
Amsterdam and England.
But with Brexit, that gets
a little more complicated.
But it's just stay within
the region for now.
And then as we get down
the road a little further,
we're looking at actually
leveraging-- what's
the new name for GKE On-Prem?
SPEAKER: Anthos.
JAMIE SIDEY: Anthos, OK, yes.
Potentially leveraging a small
footprint on the telco side
and then cleansing the
data before it goes up.
So then there's
not even anything
that's supersensitive in GCP.
But there's ways around it.
It shouldn't be a blocker.
So that's step zero.
Step one is pick your partner.
Then lift and shift
with a double bubble,
which I'll get to in a
minute, and then consolidate
and optimize like crazy.
So as far as the
migration partner,
actually, we looked at a lot
of vendors, not just three.
But we looked at three
really seriously.
And we picked Pythian because
they have a deep relationship
with Google.
And that type of kind
of stamp of approval
was meaningful for us.
And then they had the best
price and the best approach.
And so, this is worth
unpacking a little bit.
It's not that they were scraping
the bottom of the barrel.
It's that they had a world
class team of really outstanding
resources.
But it was an elastic team.
We didn't have to pay for the
whole team the whole time,
so that rolled on, rolled off.
And then they also invested
deeply in automation
so that you make the
use of the team upfront
and then automate after that.
KEITH MILLAR: Yeah, I mean,
the 17,000 virtual machines
is a big number, so
we called it brave.
It didn't really
scare us that much.
If you were here
last year, you might
have seen us talking about the
BlackBerry Messenger migration
that was done around the world.
So very similar sort of
application footprint,
not as tight a
timeline as this one.
The other good thing about
the sales cycle, if you will,
was how we were both
very outcomes focused,
not talking about hours.
And it was very
outcomes focused.
And we really--
Pythian saw this as a
great fit for both--
we have services
that we can deliver
on-prem and then remote.
And we definitely
saw the scale of this
requiring a remote component.
JAMIE SIDEY: Yeah,
and actually, riffing
on that a little bit, one
of the other things we
liked about Python was
they were very accountable.
There were multiple--
actually, a lot of check points
for if we felt it
wasn't working,
we could just stop working
with them and do it ourselves.
And that type of confident,
accountable commitment
was enormously appealing to us.
KEITH MILLAR: OK, so how
was the planning side?
Probably three
years ago, you would
see a lot of people talking
about my cloud migration
methodology.
And yes, that's important.
Yes, we have a methodology.
It's just not as important
as it was back then.
Now it really comes
down to you really
need to leverage
native components
if you're going to have
a successful migration.
So what is the knowledge
on the native side?
The other one is
the execution side.
You're talking 17,000 machines.
So how are you going
to execute that?
So planning becomes
more than just meetings.
It becomes a mix of what are
the human and software mixes
you're going to bring in
to actually execute it
in the timeline.
JAMIE SIDEY: Actually, we'll
get to this a little bit later.
But we broke all of the
machines down into easy,
medium, hard, very hard.
And the easy ones represented
the bulk of the machines.
But we'll dive into this
a little bit more later.
So what is the double bubble?
This is the thing that
your CEO and CFO will hate.
So the idea is great, I'm
going to migrate to the cloud,
and I will immediately
start spending less money.
That is not what
is going to happen.
Let's say you're at n
or at 100 on this graph.
You're going to go
from spending that
and then you're going to
ramp up your destination debt
at data center and resources.
And you're going to spend more.
And then you're going to ramp
up your migration partner,
and you're going to spend more.
So you'll get from
n to 1.5n or 2n.
And so on this graph, the
area that is above the 100,
that's the double bubble.
And if you don't plan for it,
it will bite you in the butt.
And you're going
to have a bad time.
It might seem a little
counter intuitive to also add
the migration partner on there.
You're like, ah,
that's more expensive.
If you don't do that,
and we have done this
without migration partners
before with other companies,
it just takes longer, and
you end up spending more
on the double bubble.
That migration
partner is definitely
a worthwhile investment.
KEITH MILLAR: Yeah.
We experience this in
our personal lives.
Like if you move houses,
you have an overlap
where you own two houses,
and you're probably
paying a moving company
in the middle also.
I've never heard it referred
to as the double bubble,
but it is hopefully a
phrase that catches on.
One of the themes
we're going to get into
is just if you're going to take
on a migration of this size,
it has to be not just sponsored
or supported by the C level,
it needs to be owned
by the C level.
Because this bubble is
meaningful amounts of money.
I mean, this graph
is not to scale.
JAMIE SIDEY: Right.
KEITH MILLAR: But it's a
meaningful amount of money.
And if there is
delays in the process,
then you want C
level support for it,
that the destination is
worth the double bubble,
and stay the course.
If it's just owned in
IT, for example, then you
can have C level
concern, anxiety,
a lot of awkward
discussions, that it's
going to make it
more difficult to get
through the double bubble.
JAMIE SIDEY: Yeah.
For us, the double bubble
was about six months
and about $3 million, so
not a small amount of money.
One thought on how
you shorten this,
I already mentioned using
a migration partner.
I also recommend-- if you've
got multiple data centers
you're migrating, you can
either say, OK, here they are,
and I'm going to take all
the machines of this type
and move them up,
and then this type
and move them up, et cetera.
I strongly recommend
instead saying,
I'm going to take this data
center, the whole thing.
I'm going to move
everything up that I can,
and everything that
can't move, we'll
move it to our
consolidation data center.
And then turn it off.
You can immediately turn
off the electricity.
You can not renew your lease.
You can look at can I sub these,
shrink my footprint there.
And you can start
to release the team
or the portions of the team
that you don't need anymore.
So you can start chunking
cost out, which, for us,
with 10 data centers,
that was impactful.
KEITH MILLAR: OK, so we talked
about humans and software.
So we did use an automation
migration service for this.
And a POC, so the humans
are important to figure out
the first ones, and software
is great at taking--
once it's figured out,
let software run it again,
and again, and again.
This is a bit of a busy slide.
We broke it out into
a bunch of slides
so you can understand
what it is.
But basically, humans
proved out each system type,
and that was categorized.
And then an inventory
was executed against.
So the inventory, it actually
wasn't that shocking a piece
of technology.
I think it was just
Google Sheets that we
wrote these systems into.
Some of them were super easy to
inventory and through software.
Others were very hard.
And I think you're going to
get into that later, Jamie,
about that.
JAMIE SIDEY: Yeah.
KEITH MILLAR: And so that
was all written in inventory.
That was the execution plan.
Then the automation service
looked at that inventory,
pulled server names from it.
A automation agent was
attempted to be installed
on the on-premise machine.
If that was successful,
then you kept going.
If not, it was put in the
deal with later bucket--
basically, the human
attendant bucket.
The agent would then
replicate that OS instance.
It would take it to GCS,
Google Cloud Storage.
Once that was verified
as a real image,
it was then taken
and instantiated
in GCE, Google Compute
Engine, as a VM.
And that would be then flagged
into the inventory as OK.
And then not OKs were then sent
for human involvement later.
And that's really how--
and it was an iterative
process because new inventory
would show up as the
process was executing.
Engineers had to
handle the exception.
So the obvious question
that everyone asked
is what was your success rate?
And it's kind of
as you would think.
For the systems that were
quite well understood,
recent versions of Windows,
recent versions of Linux,
we had about a 90% success rate.
And then the ones that were
older versions of those
had about an 80% failure rate.
So you can imagine
where your humans were
spending their time, was
all on the exceptions.
And the sort of rote
Windows and rote Linux boxes
were very much handled
through the migration process.
So that's how you get that
many machines moved in,
well, call it six months.
JAMIE SIDEY: Yeah.
So some challenges
we encountered
during the migration.
If you boil it down,
it's the middle one.
There is just too
much crap there.
We had a business that was
formed by multiple acquisitions
and bolt-ons.
And so we had more
than 50 flavors of OS,
all sorts of different
varieties of Linux and Windows,
but also AIX, HP-UX, Solaris.
So we said, all right,
everything that's on Windows,
upgrade to a recent version
that will be supported.
And keep only one
or two versions,
and be disciplined about that.
Do the same thing with Linux.
And then for all of your other
flavors of operating system,
do you really, really need it?
Like really, really?
Can you shut that down?
Can you move that load
onto something else?
And in some cases, we could.
Can you refactor?
But in the cases where
you couldn't, fine.
Keep that.
Keep it on bare metal.
Consolidate in one data center.
So we went from 50 plus
flavors down to about 10.
So we had 80% reduction there.
And then on the
too much crap side,
there is a mindset with
physical data centers
where, hey, I bought
all this stuff.
If I'm not using it, I'm
kind of wasting the resource
that I paid for.
So I might as well use it.
And if there isn't real
discipline on the team,
then you can fill that up.
And then the team that's
managing the data center
says, oh my god, we're
at 95% utilization.
We should maybe buy some more
hardware, so then you buy more.
And then you use
that, et cetera.
So the way we
handled this was we
did a physical inventory,
which takes actually longer
than we expected it to.
And then we had departments
have to claim each machine
and explain why it
needed to be migrated.
And then everything that didn't
get claimed, we turned off.
And then inevitably,
hands were raised.
I do actually need
that, and here's why.
And that's fine.
We're not trying to
be jerks about it.
It was more just, hey,
let's not migrate anything
that isn't truly needed.
We cut our migration
effort by about 50%
just doing this, which
realistically, this exercise
probably should've
been an annual one
or more frequent
than that anyway.
But it cut our effort a lot.
Then tiny pipes, I'm sure
all of you have lots of data.
We certainly did.
And if you try and push
that over the pipe that
is good for day to day use,
it's going to take forever.
Strong recommendation is to use
the Google Transfer Appliance
if that works for you.
So I think that's
in North America,
and I think it's
in beta in Europe.
So we used it in North America,
and we used it in Europe.
For those of you who aren't
familiar with what that is,
it's a big box that has
a bunch of storage on it.
It shows up at your data center.
You load your data in,
ship it back to Google,
and then they load it.
In India, where that
wasn't available,
we used a GCP partner called--
I'm going to mispronounce
that, but I think it's Sify.
KEITH MILLAR: Sify, yeah.
JAMIE SIDEY: And that
cut our migration time--
increased the pipe size
and cut our migration time
from about seven months
down to six weeks.
KEITH MILLAR: Yeah--
sorry, just if I can add on
to the tiny pipes picture.
From our teams, we
see this as being
a chronic problem in
a lot of migrations,
is when you're moving that
many VMs, think about root
C drives, how much data that is
that you're going to be moving.
It's certainly not going
to be the bandwidth you
use on a daily basis, right?
But it's also-- it's
not just the bandwidth.
It's the resiliency
of that network.
One of the things
we ran into in this
was a network equipment
component failure,
which it failed.
We tried to troubleshoot it.
At some point, you just have
to give up on troubleshooting,
and we just put in a new one.
We replaced it.
And I'm not even sure
if we ever figured out
what the problem of it was.
But we would have
found that if we
had run a two-day hammer test
to battle test the network.
And that's, I think,
sometimes there's
easy to do the calculations
on the bandwidth
that you've set up
from a provider,
but do you have all the
failure points of a network
and making sure
that you have run
a multi-day test against that?
On the networking side
also, yes, the data transfer
appliance does work very well.
And we recommend using that.
It is kind of networking.
Lock down the components.
Lock down security as much
as you can before you move.
And then, also, don't
give more internet access
than you had on-prem.
Even though cloud
might tend to make
you do that, if you
have a limited amount
of internet access,
perhaps none,
don't change that
as you move over,
is sort of another
networking tip.
JAMIE SIDEY: Yeah,
totally agree.
Too slow, need robots.
So we had thousands of
machines we needed to migrate.
If we had done this by hand--
as a friend of
mine says, lovingly
handcrafted-- it
would have taken ages.
And there definitely would
have been human error.
And then the knock-on
effects would have been
unpredictable and not good.
So for a migration
of any scale, you've
got to invest in automation.
And then the dog
ate my password.
This was a problem
with the inventorying
and with the automation.
We were a turnaround
situation and bleeding money.
And we couldn't afford to wait.
And so by the time we actually
started the data center
migration, a lot
of the team that
had been managing some of
those machines were gone.
So I think we had like
20% of our machines,
we didn't have the
passwords for so.
We had to send people into the
data centers to reset those.
And it wasn't like we
identified all of them at once
and did it in batch.
It was kind of we discovered it,
and send someone in, and then
discovered it, and
sent someone in.
So recommendation
would be make sure
that you have the
passwords upfront, which
seems like a no-brainer, but
it can bite you in the butt.
So now I'm in GCP.
Now what?
So it can be a bit of a
runaway roller coaster
if you're not careful.
You've got a team that's used
to, hey, there's this resource.
And there's almost
no incremental cost
if I spin up more stuff than
that, to now, everything
you spin up costs you money.
And you can burn a
lot of cash very,
very quickly if
you're not careful.
So first recommendation here
is, like you said, lock it down.
So lock down the
internet access.
But in terms of
provisioning new resources,
nobody gets rights
to do this anymore.
It's centralized to
your SaaS ops team.
Have a request system with
a form or whatever, where
people say, I want this.
This is how much
resource I want.
This is the project it's for.
This is the layer of the
application it's for.
This is my budget.
This is how long I need it for.
And yeah, it's a
pain in the butt.
And there'll be some
pushback initially.
But then the team gets on board
with it, and they're fine.
If you don't do this, you're
going to have a bad time.
I promise you.
And this then ties into
labeling all of the resources.
And then you can
monitor and keep
track of are you staying above
or below your budget target.
As far as reduce and simplify,
we had four different support
ticket tracking systems.
We had eight different
source control systems.
We had 120 plus RDP boxes.
The list goes on, right?
So we said, OK, we're going
to adopt one ticket tracking
system.
And we're going to
move from eight down
to one source control system.
And we're going to go
from 120 RDP servers
down to four, et cetera,
et cetera, right?
Take that approach
everywhere you
can to converge on the one
system for a given function
and to make more efficient
use of the resources.
KEITH MILLAR: On
those, you had the easy
through most difficult systems.
And at the bottom, one of the
casualties was the HP-UX boxes.
I'm assuming someone made a
compelling case that those
had to stay and had to move.
How did you deal with that?
JAMIE SIDEY: I don't
remember exactly what they
were being used for,
but I think it was one
of the source control systems.
And so we turned them off.
So that took care of that.
KEITH MILLAR: So just
back to the C level?
JAMIE SIDEY: Yeah.
KEITH MILLAR: I need to
get to a destination that
has a good cost footprint
and driving that through.
JAMIE SIDEY: Yeah.
Yeah.
So once you've done
your consolidation,
set extreme goals.
So I mentioned earlier
that the team that
had been there when
we got involved,
their approach was well, we can
get 10%, 20%, 30% improvement.
If you set extreme goals, it
forces people to be creative.
They have to re-evaluate
their assumptions
and say, god, if I'm
going to get 90%,
how am I even going to do that?
Maybe we don't need this system.
Maybe we can consolidate,
as opposed to yeah,
we'll keep everything,
but can we just
be a little more efficient?
So set the goal posts out there.
And this is another place that
you need that C suite buy-in
because if you don't have that
and you set extreme goals,
someone's going to go
screaming up the flagpole,
and then you'll get pushback.
So how do you optimize?
First one is easy, right?
Take advantage of the
GCP pricing hooks.
So use sustained use discounts,
committed use discounts.
If you don't need something
to be outside of the US,
keep your load in the US.
You get the best
pricing that way.
Those are the easy ones.
Monitor everything.
So everything has to be tagged.
Monitor CPU, memory
disk utilization.
I used to work at
Dell 15 years ago,
and Michael Dell's
big thing is--
what is it?
If you can measure it,
you can improve it.
So make sure you are
measuring everything.
And that way, you can track,
how much have I spent on this?
What's my velocity?
Am I going to go above or below
my budget for the quarter?
And it's OK.
If you're tracking, you go
above it, maybe you need to,
but you can catch it soon enough
that you can adjust course
and dial back other stuff.
Or maybe you're going
over budget in a bad way,
and you can catch that fast.
And then being
ruthlessly efficient,
so re-platform Windows to
Linux, which is a hassle.
But do it.
You'll save money.
Delete unattached
disks every day.
Delete snapshots and images
as soon as they're not needed.
If you don't need solid
state, don't use it.
And there's valid reasons
to use solid state.
So I'm not saying don't use it.
But if you don't need
it, don't use it.
It costs more.
And then make use of
the recommendations
that GCP gives you.
They'll say, hey,
this machine is only
running at 20% CPU utilization.
Maybe you should shrink it.
Use those.
Don't rely exclusively on that.
You're going to want to
do your own analysis.
But definitely make use of that.
Automate.
So we've talked about
automation during migration.
Automation afterwards
is also important.
We now auto terminate
anything that isn't labeled.
Initially, we weren't
enforcing the labeling.
So when we put this policy
in, we gave people a heads up.
We're like, OK,
after this point,
things will be terminated.
And then we would give them, for
the first two or three cycles,
we said, hey, these
resources aren't labeled.
We're going to turn
them off tomorrow.
Now we don't even wait.
If it's not labeled
properly, it gets killed.
Also, look for some kind of
standard patterns of use.
So you can probably
turn the machines off
at night that your engineers
are using and on the weekend.
It's not that they
can't turn them
back on if they
need to work late
at night or over the weekend,
but turn that stuff off
if it's not needed.
Look for other patterns like
if your testing team only
needs the testing environment
in the first and third week
of the month, great.
Turn that environment
off the rest of the time.
And then use auto
scaling smartly.
That can be helpful, too.
On the second one,
go GCP native.
So there's two mindsets here.
One mindset is I really want
to stay agnostic, right?
I don't want to get fully
committed to one cloud provider
because then I'm locked in,
and I lose pricing pressure.
That's not the direction
we went because if you
do that, then you
can't take advantage
of all the great things that
the cloud provider brings
to the table.
For us, with GCP, Spanner
is phenomenal, right?
It's a game changer
for us, and we're not
doing like a generic
it's a database thing.
We're doing it's Spanner,
and we're using all the hooks
that we can in it.
We're also going full
bore on GKE On-Prem,
which is now called Anthos.
The name hasn't
stuck in my head yet,
but we're going full
bore on that as well.
So we recommend
going and embracing
that the GCP is your provider
and really go full bore
on what they bring to the table.
They invest a ton of
money in this stuff.
And it's worth using.
KEITH MILLAR: Yeah, we get
asked this quite often,
is how do I architect
my application
so that I can quickly move
from one cloud to the other?
This was actually
the same discussion
we had back in the
database space.
How can I build an
application for this database,
but move it to any other?
Our advice then is
the same as it is now
on cloud, which is
if you architect
your application properly and
leverage native capabilities
of the cloud, you
will be better off
than trying to do some
heterogeneous shim
layer that you can rapidly
move from cloud to cloud.
You'll never get there.
You couldn't do it on database.
I don't think you'll
do it on cloud.
So if you architect
your apps properly,
then you will spend
less if you decide
to move than trying to bet
on the future of a move.
Commit to the platform
that you're engineering on,
and leverage the
native components.
JAMIE SIDEY: Yep.
And this last point,
papers please--
so make sure that you're
collecting the certificates
as you decommission hardware.
You may get audited, and having
that paperwork is helpful.
We did, and it was helpful.
So how did we do?
So we started at
15 million a year.
We are currently at 4 million
a year after six months.
So we've saved 11
million already,
which even factoring in the
3 million double bubble,
it's more than paid for itself.
And we're going to get to
1.5 million by next quarter.
So that 90% target, we
are going to hit it.
And that's all in, right?
That's including our
GCP spend as well
and the team that's
dedicated to it.
And if you look at all the
different other metrics
that I mentioned
at the beginning--
how many data centers,
square footage,
electricity, et
cetera, et cetera--
we've cut between 80%
and 100% on everyone.
But the big metric for
us is cash out the door.
And this has been
enormously successful
from that standpoint.
KEITH MILLAR: And
these 10 data centers,
that was sort of due
to the serial acquiring
nature of the business.
That's how you got
10 data centers.
That's how you had so many
footprints, so many engineers.
JAMIE SIDEY: Yeah.
Yeah.
I mean, we ended up with--
I think we had three data
centers just in Germany,
which we really didn't need.
And we had two in India.
We had one in Rio.
And we had one in Kansas City.
And it was just
all-- and Toronto.
It was all over the place.
And the ones in India
were customer driven.
But the other ones was just--
it came with the acquisitions.
So takeaways.
Pick your partners carefully.
Clearly, we like
GCP and Pythian.
Plan for the double bubble.
It's going to happen.
And if you aren't
planning for it,
it will bite you in the butt,
and you'll have a bad time.
Do set extreme goals.
It forces the team
to get creative.
And initially, there's a
little bit of a oh my god,
what the hell are you thinking?
But it works out.
And then own it at the C level
if you want results like this.
KEITH MILLAR: Yeah, I'll just
add color to the governed lift
and shift.
Because I know
lift and shift can
have a bad connotation with it.
That can mean your CFO is
not happy at the end of it.
This was what was called
a governed lift and shift.
So a lot of housecleaning
done beforehand.
Again, owned at the C
level and then [INAUDIBLE]..
You could argue--
I think, Jamie,
you did earlier-- saying
you could do this.
You could have
done this on-prem.
But what we see is
just people don't.
There's no big rip in the fabric
that causes you to actually,
well, first, get the money
to do it, and secondly, paint
a destination that's
really compelling.
So much like-- all
digital transformation
now really means cloud.
That's because you have the
mandate to go through this.
So clean it up.
I mean, you didn't talk about
it on the previous slide,
but going from 50 OS instance
types to support down to seven
is huge.
Right?
JAMIE SIDEY: Yeah.
KEITH MILLAR: And that
makes a massive difference.
The other piece-- and I call
this the surprise invoice
that drives CFO's crazy.
You guys were very
frugal with who
you gave rights to actually
go spend up more assets.
JAMIE SIDEY: Yeah.
KEITH MILLAR: That's
critical, because even if you
land in your destination
and the price
is really good for February, if
it blows up in March and April,
then you haven't really
achieved anything.
So really figure out who needs
the rights to set up those
clusters, who needs those.
And only give them
out to people who
are accountable to the business
for that increased spend.
JAMIE SIDEY: Yep.
Yeah, and we did that right here
because we made that mistake
on other deals.
So that was a painfully
learned lesson.
And then the last point on
here, monitor everything.
Do be ruthless.
And I can't stress enough.
The default configuration
will just be to monitor CPU.
But you really want to monitor
memory and disk utilization
as well.
And you want to have everything
labeled so that you can quickly
dive in and say, OK, I'm
spending 2,000 more per day
than I was expecting.
Where did that come from?
OK.
George, what's going on?
Why are you suddenly
spending more?
[MUSIC PLAYING]